افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد 13 شخصا
واصابه اخرين جلهم من الاطفال في قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف منزلا لعائله جمعه في
منطقه زوايده وسط قطع
غزه
هنا في جره غاز مش بنت تنفيذ جره غاز
الحرمه قالت بنتي مع هنا
البنت بتكون ميته هذه اكد
بط وين
بطانيه قديش فيها عدد المنطقه لقينا شهداء
مليانين
شباب اذا في حرام
[موسيقى]
هنا
اطلعنا يمكن حتى الان سبعه شهداء طب
بالطلع المنزل قديش يسكن فيه يعني والله
ما احنا عارفين احنا م الجران فوق ال 50
فوق ال 50 فوق ال 50 واحد في وساع تحت
الانقاض ه موجودين لحتى الان هيهم تحت
الانقاض في موجودين يعني اغلبهم اطفال
صحيح يعني ما يعادل يمكن
اطفال سبعه في
موجودين ي والله اكسر ايدي كسر ارفع
كده يا
معلم يا معلم
شهيد ايش
صار توكل على الله توكل على امشي يلا اطلع
اطلع امشي
عل خدي فوق امسك يا
اد